right I want to know I want to know the
whole thing I want to know as far into
this as you can tell me why you think
this like instead of me just saying no
you're wrong I want to I want you to
explain it to me I want to know whether
or not I trust your process do you bring
that skill home with you
yeah I mean you're surrounded by women's
drop it stuff bro I'm serious like
sometimes because I even see it with my
own husband we have three daughters but
I mean especially you know when you have
a pretty masculine male I'm always
fascinated to watch them navigate their
home if it when they're surrounded by
women I just give up most of the time I
lose every argument I think you know I
tried to we communicate a lot love
talking with girls it's always those
things they're crying about like okay
okay okay we're gonna be fine
and you know I don't want them to be
like me I want them to be themselves and
I wanted to be girls I wanted to be able
to be themselves I don't want them to
mirror my resilience you know I want
them to be vulnerable if they want to be
vulnerable but it's in terms of like how
I decorate the house or any I have no
say oh no nothing you know that's why
you have you know I have this place I
was gonna say you have your your cave
here and Laird has a barn perfect and he
you know when he meets young guys
getting married he goes here I'm gonna
teach you okay you're right honey I'm
sorry
and oh yes whatever color you choose
always work some people it's never
enough but if you have the right
relationship sometimes it'll work that
way cuz I don't give a fuck what my
house looks like I really don't know I
have a good view where's the coffee yeah
okay good real work yeah okay how's the
bed that's a good bed do we have a TV
where's the TV is it a good one ought to
get TV all right we're good laughs top
okay we're good yeah yeah I don't need
that much now you know so like when my
wife's like I'm gonna put this here okay
put it there fantastic I want to get
that painting okay get the painting I
don't know I don't know where you want
to put it yeah put it where it feels
right I don't give a fuck it's I think
it's smart I I mean you know like
sometimes if I am fringe on if it's
functional then layered steps in like
you know that's not really functional
but otherwise he's like I'm tearing some
stuff out of my house right now and he
just gives me a look and I'm like I'm
this age if I want to do this support me
and he just laughs and walks out yeah he
does probably don't care go ahead just
yes it's in the way whatever it is
whatever have fun with it yeah is what
time's dinner you know love to decorate
things I get nervous I was really into
it well yeah it's a nesting trip yeah
guys are like really into like like
design in in their own house like really
really into it like constantly obsessing
about where things are and we're like
homosexuals yeah what do you mean is
that a stereotypical thing that is
outrageous was that racist that might be
you might have showed your white
supremacy I'm not exactly sure yeah it's
a funny thing right but if I didn't have
this place though I don't know if I like
traditionally men had pool halls they
could hang out it or gyms that they
would hang out in and they would get
their dose of time and ask you Linna tea
yeah her basement or a basement yeah you
kind of need a place where nobody's
touching your stuff no yeah well if you
live in a house like I do with all girls
too it's it's just everything's girly I
just do whatever I'm fine Laird says
he's like I needed to be more specific I
said I wanted to be surrounded by women
I didn't mean be related to all of them
that's hilarious you know it's I think
it's nature God's Way of balancing off
they say if guys have elevated body
temperature so athletes people train a
lot that they're statistically have a
greater chance of having daughters
because I think they hot we call it hot
balls basically if kills off the male
sperm
that's hilarious and if you look at real
I think so they did a thing on a bunch
of guys either in the NFL or whatever
and statistically they just have a lot
more daughters
huh and I think it's like nature's way
of going oh you're gonna be all like
moving and active and raw and all this
stuff guess what we're just gonna put a
bunch of girls around for you
my daughter's say things to my husband I
could never say as a wife mmm you know
it's like I see it and I just go oh yeah
while they know that for sure he loves
them so they carry it away with it
they're in yeah they can't get fired no
I always say that to them
my youngest daughter when she was really
little like five or six she'd say okay
so I'm not really clear with this when I
have a long time I'm by myself
and when you and Dad need a long time
like you're together and I try to like
well you know it's important for moms
and dads because you know we have to
work it I go you know you're you're
always going to be dad's daughter I you
know I'm we're working at being a
husband and wife and then she'd keep
going with it I finally would just say
like hey do you want to have Christmas
in separate houses and I'd see her think
for a second like well maybe you know
she's processing that she's like I miss
you but I don't know you know so it's
all that dance you know no cuz daughters
man they don't miss a trick and they're
on you and they're on their dad like
nobody's business well my friends that
have sons the way they say it is it's
like you take one of two things either
you have this wild animal that's tearing
things apart or you have someone who's
screaming and crying about something you
don't understand yeah take your pick you
want to know yeah mental destroyer or a
physical destroyer
yeah walls with holes and Bochum broken
bones good boys and girls it's like I
have learned so much being a mother two
daughters and I've been around women my
whole life you figure playing volleyball
being around tons of women it's very
different as a parent I mean I've
learned the most especially teenagers
watching them grow so strange it's such
a strange experience watching a person
figure out the world from from jump you
know like out the womb figure out the
world it's so educational I feel I don't
think everyone should have children I'm
not one of those zealots that tells
everybody hey you're not alive till you
have a kid no I think it's unfair to say
that to people it is unfair I think it's
first well a lot of people can't write
and maybe they have just a different
path like I always do my girlfriend's
too like it's unfair also to romanticize
like to your friends who either opted
not
have children or whatever met a partner
too later didn't or whatever because I
think it is a really rich I mean there's
nothing like it I mean I love my
children but if I had one friend she was
like got married later and she was like
you know we're gonna adopt and she was
also doing a new business and I was like
listen I need to come I want to talk to
you
and she also like to consider taking
naps occasionally I was like if you
think you're gonna adopt and like you're
gonna have a 12 year old that's like hey
I really appreciate you guys thank you
so much I go that's not what you know
like if you think you're gonna have a
kid and it's gonna make you happier
that's not what having a kid is I think
it makes you it makes you know yourself
better in a different way and you can
adapt and do something different but I
think when people sort of sell that bill
of goods like you gotta have kids it's
like well do you want to have kids you
know I think it's like you said not for
everyone you definitely shouldn't adopt
you think it's gonna be easy that's what
I mean I get a romantic idea of like and
I go you know you don't first of all you
don't know what the what's where the kid
is coming from and then also you have a
romant I think every parent going into
it has a romantic idea I did and I'm a
pretty realistic person of like I'm
gonna do all these things right and it
we're gonna be you know running in
sunflower fields together and my kids
are never gonna think my music sucks or
I can't drive and then you realize I had
a friend tell me everyone gets their
turn in the barrel no matter what you do
yeah you got you have to navigate stuff
you're gonna have to deal with stuff
yeah and on the other hand it's awesome
when someone does adopt people if
they're really into it if they know what
they're getting into and those martyrs
out there and those people that are just
super kind and generous and love to
adopt children that god bless them yeah
so glad they were there yeah it's just I
agree with you that there are some
people that have a romanticized idea of
what it's like to raise a child and it's
unfair to to sell it like I love the
moms like what so when you gonna have
number two or whatever to somebody it's
like oh you know that they're behind
closed doors doing you know like they
just want everyone to be in the
psychotic nests with them I have three
kids you should have three kids you know
there are people like that right they
did yeah there's people that have a kid
that immediately take this moral high
ground like yeah like they're doing
something they're an adult and you're
you're just a fool yeah you're like I
wonder who is the fool that's its I ask
myself that sometimes well don't you
think you're a better person for raising
kids does it make you feel like you're
more in tune and nicer and just more
aware of what it what it means to be a
human yeah I not only that I I feel like
I feel like it's it's a forced
exploration if you're trying to
participate like if you just lay down
the law and go hey in this house this is
how we do it then you're not doing
anything but I think if you you've
learned to adapt and also go wow I was
doing that wrong for like ten years
amazing you know like I've one of my
daughters at 12 or 13 sort of revealed
some stuff about what she was unhappy
about about my parenting and I was like
god I've been doing that for a long time
so I think it's it's cool that she had
the confidence to do that though yeah
it's so cool I wanted to hear that like
when she was 30 at the Thanksgiving
table
she moved out I was like what you're
supposed to reveal all that like after
you move out and then I go oh what did I
do that sorry what time's your flight I
know I know listen it's a it's a
surrender I think for me it's been a
real surrender because I I just think I
you think you're in control of stuff and
you think I've got some discipline and
work ethic I just work my way through it
or power my way through it and then you
realize like no you have to surrender
and and also it's not just about solving
it quickly and yeah it is I'm I know
myself certainly better but also it
forces you if you're willing to to
really expand yeah